Peggy 18
hello I'm Omar Shakir the native
director to have Vilanch Studios New
York working on Just Cause 4
in this mission Rico's pursuing a
massive tornado as it weaves a path of
destruction throughout the grasslands
and this is the storm chaser the only
vehicle that allows them to do so all
right let's see what this thing can do
thanks to avalanches need a tax engine
everything you see as well as the
trajectory of every spiraling object is
being calculated in real time
[Music]
please don't chaser and get out of here
I'll get a tornado back on track
the black hand have taken over Solis is
private Airport and to progress Rico
must take out the wind cans that are
holding the tornado at bay
the offs the player can take out the
wind cannons in any way they choose
right now we're using the railgun one of
the many new weapons in the game
and all these new weapons have a
secondary fire option so in this case
the railgun can shoot a powerful beam of
energy and it can also deploy a drone
that will fight alongside Rico you can
even use this drone as a grapple point
to propel yourself into the air
for the next cannon let's get more
creative and use some new features of
Rico's graphic eyes
that's all we're gonna show today it's
just a small glimpse of what to expect
and Just Cause 4 and there's plenty more
to come when you play yourself on
December 4th
[Music]